ahora resolvamos el problema número 43
describa la gráfica de la siguiente
ecuación
que se muestra aquí básicamente lo que
nos piden es dejar esto con formato de
ecuación cuadrática estándar y para eso
debemos completar el cuadrado tanto para
x como para y separamos los términos que
tienen que ver con x este y este lo voy
a escribir aquí en azul los términos en
x x cuadrado + 4x aquí tengo que agregar
algo para que aquí tenga una ecuación
cuadrática perfecta y voy a agregar lo
que se desee pueden dar cuenta que voy a
agregar voy a agregar aquí un 4
pero si agregó aquí algo tengo que
restar lo así que después de mí igual
aquí debo tener también otro 4 voy a
agregar 4 en ambos lados de esta
ecuación
y ahora voy a escribir en verde los
términos de ya que son estos
esto así que es más de cuadrada
-6 y que tengo que agregar aquí para
tener una ecuación cuadrática perfecta
este es menos 6-3 3-6 6-3 al cuadrado va
a ser igual a 9 así que aquí tengo que
agregar un 9
+ 9 y si agregó algo acá lo tengo que
agregar también de este otro lado de
hecho lo voy a escribir con el otro
color moradito mejor para que se note
que yo le estoy agregando un es parte de
la ecuación original + 9 y si le agrego
de este lado también tengo que agregar
de este otro lado y mi último término
que queda es el menos 3 este de aquí que
lo escribo acá menos 3
escribí esto de esta manera esta parte
de acá para poder sustituirlo como x
2 al cuadrado
justamente por eso agregue este 4 para
poder hacer esto factorizar lo aquí y
este también le agregue el más 9 para
que se note que es un 9
poderlo factorizar de esta manera y
menos 3
al cuadrado y aquí bueno tengo este
menos tres menos tres y este es un más
hecho esto se suman
que esto es igual a 94 es igual a 13
puede simplificar un poco más voy a
escribirlo todo de un color ya que la
factorización x + 2 al cuadrado
al menos tres y menos tres al cuadrado
sumo tres en ambos lados de esta
ecuación y me quedan tres menos tres va
0 13 + 3 va a ser 16
y si lo piensan esta ecuación es la de
un círculo la ecuación de un círculo
este 6 nos escribió bien 16 la ecuación
de un círculo tiene este formato
x
- ah
al cuadrado
massié - ve al cuadrado más o menos b
al cuadrado igual a r al cuadrado donde
el centro del círculo está en el valor
en el que la x 0 y la aie se hacer así
que para que esto sea igual a 0 esta x
ésta tiene que ser igual a menos 2
ya tendrá que ser igual a 3 esta es la
coordenada del centro de esta
circunferencia o de este círculo y el
radio va a ser 4 4 x 4 es 16 el radio es
igual a 4 así que la respuesta es un
círculo con centro en menos 2,3 y con
radio en 4 que es la opción de
veamos el siguiente problema
44 cuál es la solución de la ecuación 5
x 17 podemos escribir esto con formato
logarítmico como logaritmo logaritmo
base 5 de 17
igual a equis pero ninguna de las
opciones está en este formato y ninguna
calculadora tiene el logaritmo base 5 o
que íbamos a reescribir lo así x igual a
logaritmo base 5 logaritmo base 5 de 17
los pasados sobre logaritmos demostramos
que esta propiedad que voy a escribir
aquí x igual a logaritmo
en cualquier base que llamo ve de
cualquier otro número que llamó a es
igual a logaritmo en base 10 de a entre
el logaritmo logaritmo en base 10 debe
puede ser base 10 puede ser logaritmo
natural cualquier otro logaritmo pongo
base 10 porque es que todas las
calculadoras tienen así que es bastante
conveniente así que aquí cuál será
y cuál será b este es b
este es a puede escribir x es igual al
logaritmo base de 10 logaritmos base 10
de 17 entre el logaritmo base 10 de 5
qué es la opción d
ahora el siguiente problema número 45 si
el organismo va a ser 10 de x es igual a
menos 2 cuál es el valor de x
eso es lo mismo que decir que en 10 a la
menos 2 es igual a x el número de aquí
abajo junto a logaritmo es la base y el
número que está aquí después del igual
es la potencia a la que tenemos que
elevar esta base para obtener esta x
entonces tenemos que esto es igual a 1
entre 10 al cuadrado igual a x
esto es igual a 1 entre 100
que es nuestra opción c
el siguiente problema el número 46
la ecuación es equivalente al logaritmo
base 3 de un noveno igual a x
lo mismo que la pregunta anterior 3
elevado a la equis va a ser igual a un
noveno 1 entre 9 y esta es la opción se
vaya esto fue sospechosamente fácil
siguiente problema número 47
es el primer paso incorrecto al
simplificar el logaritmo base 4 de 4
entre 64
aquí tenemos estos tres pasos veamos el
primero
este primer paso logaritmo base 4 de 4
entre 64 es igual a logaritmo base 4 de
4 menos logaritmo base 4 de 64 el primer
paso es correcto al tener una división
en el organismo es equivalente a restar
el logaritmo del denominador al
logaritmo de el numerador así que este
primer paso está bien este va bien a qué
número tenemos que elevar 4 para que nos
dé 4a pues a 1 esto está bien qué número
tenemos que elevar 4 para tener 64
veamos 4 elevado a la 1 es igual a 4 4
al cuadrado es igual a 16 4 elevado al
cubo es igual a 64 aquí está el error
cuatro de las 16 como esto esto esté mal
esto lo veremos base 4 de 64 estrés
esto debe ser un 3
es 1 - 3 el resultado nos debe dar menos
2 aquí en el paso 2 es donde se cometió
el primer error nuestro último problema
de este vídeo es el número 48
tenemos que memo leo gabi y mariana han
trabajado en el mismo problema de
matemáticas en el pizarrón el trabajo de
cada estudiante se muestra a
continuación su maestro dice que aunque
dos de ellos tienen la respuesta
correcta sólo uno de ellos llegó a la
solución correcta usando los pasos
correctos vamos a analizar quién fue y
nos decimos lo que hizo menos bueno de
entrada me mostra mal porque aquí no
puede ser x a la menos 7 igual a 1 /
quizá la menos 7 x a la menos 7 es igual
a 1 entre x a las 7 así que esto de
entrada está mal veamos que él y su
hogar
ok tenemos x al cubo entre x a las 7
aquí va bien esto es 1 / quizá la cuarta
baja va bien cuando x es diferente de
ser
es candidato a estar bien vamos a ver
qué masaje que hizo leo
hizo el mismo error que vemos x al cubo
entre x a la menos 7 esto está mal
aunque aquí no sé por qué tuvo este
resultado que se parece que es el mismo
que sacó gabi pero de todas maneras este
este procedimiento esto está mal y vemos
que hizo mariana x al cubo entre x a las
7 esto va bien pero aquí es no es x a la
cuarta tres menos siete es menos cuatro
entonces ésta está mal así que la
persona que encontrar la solución
correcta usando los pasos correctos fue
gabi y es aquí llegamos en este vídeo
nos vemos en el siguiente